a lego movie too was directed by Mike
Mitchell no longer directed by Lord and
Miller but they did stay on as
screenwriters and this film follows the
first which beautifully set up this
universe and I have loved to at least
semi enjoyed every lego movie since then
and after the first film revealed that
this was really a universe in which kids
were playing with Legos and it was sort
of like this fantastical version of what
was going on in the kids minds this one
goes deeper into that and we see a
brother and sister who are arguing they
can't play well together and thusly the
Lego universe has become this Mad Max
post-apocalyptic like world where Emmett
is one of the last few people that still
thinks everything is awesome whereas
everyone else is trying to convince him
no not really
we got issues here and there's these
invaders that are coming in that are
threatening to ruin everything which is
told from the perspective of the sister
who is now threatening to roon the
brothers universe that he's created I'm
sorry this review is as late as it is I
have a lot going on right now in my life
I have a short film that's coming out
very soon in a festival March first I'm
in pre-production on another one which
involved going to an abandoned farmhouse
and scouting that location and making
sure it was safe insurance liability all
of that a lot of information but
basically I didn't have enough time to
sit down and review every film that came
out last weekend because I've just been
so goddamn busy but I am excited to get
going again with a lot more reviews
because I got a lot of stuff to come out
very soon a lot of stuff I'm filming but
lego movie 2 this movie was entertaining
I didn't like it as much as the first
one though I think the first one was a
lot smarter and it felt like a movie
that was made more for adults and kids
could also enjoy it this movie feels a
lot more aimed at pleasing the mass
which is strange because the first one
really did and I don't know why this
feels so much more family-friendly yeah
there's still adult jokes to be found in
the film there's still moments of satire
that really worked for me because all
the lego films have that even the
Ninjago movie which I liked more than
most this one definitely aims more at
just pleasing the base demographic of
kids and there's moments for adults to
like to but it's nowhere near as
smarter as clever as the first film
still it is an enjoyable movie for sure
the animation is incredible there's
really exciting action scenes there's a
few great musical numbers there's some
great in jokes if you are aware of
movies and pop culture which is very
popular for the lego films Batman has
some very funny moments in the movie as
well but I think my biggest issue with
the movie is that the second act sets up
an arc that once the third act comes
which I won't spoil it makes the second
act less interesting it makes the
build-up seem rather inconsequential
because now that you know things that
are going on everything that was set up
in the second act seems like it's
worthless now and I feel like on repeat
viewings that will suffer because now
the entire middle portion of the movie
it's not what you think it was in a way
and so when Yuri watch the movie it's
gonna be hard to gain an interest in
some of these scenes that are supposed
to be setting up things that never come
to fruition there's also some things
that happen towards the end in regards
to these story reveals that I saw like a
mile away there's some really obvious
twists in the movie but as far as voice
work the movies excellently done Chris
Pratt is really good as Emmet's although
I didn't like Emmet as much in this one
as I did the first time around
I think his gleeful optimism in the
first film seemed more realistic because
it wasn't a Mad Max post-apocalyptic
world whereas in this one where like all
of the Lego characters are depressed and
they're sad and life just sucks for them
he's the only guy walking around still
listening to everything is awesome and
so it kind of makes him seem stupid but
Elizabeth Banks as Lucy was probably my
favorite character in this film she's
super badass and funny and tough and I
related to her the most because she just
kind of spoke what the audience was
thinking most of the time like when
Emmet would say something just
over-the-top she would be like that
level-headed person it's like would you
just stop right now but even though the
third act does sort of betray the setup
of the second act
it did have a super super heartwarming
point to it all one that I understood
and one that I really agreed with
because I have sisters and when we were
kids we didn't really get along that
well and it was difficult for us to want
to like play together or do anything
because we were both on kind of
different mindsets and so I liked the
third act and how it wrapped things up
and I thought it was something that
little kids and older kids can really
appreciate and learn something from but
just because the message is good it
doesn't necessarily mean that it worked
it's definitely something that I think
kids should know about and should think
about but it doesn't 100% work narrative
Lee for me but still just as an
animation film this was very
entertaining and well done
although nowhere near as good as the
first film I'm gonna give the lego movie
to the second part of B - guys thank you
so much as always for watching look
forward to more reviews very soon and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]